all you have to do is create the new
lazy saturday
theme song guys
i bought a course
[Music]
ear to ear baby excuse me i'm just so
nervous
let me just say the winner today
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
welcome to an episode of lazy saturday
that's right
hey it's it's a reddit day guys i'm
doing something a little different guys
to start out
if you want to join if you want to join
the experience you can go to coffeezilla
underscore gg
guys we had a contest last week and i
have not
checked any of the stuff posts okay
and remember the highest upvoted song uh
becomes our theme song
so we'll roll us the theme song at the
end i don't want to give it away i want
to give the winner away but we'll listen
to it all together we'll be watching
some memes if you guys enjoy this
leave a comment below it's the end of
the week look relax we cover the
scammers
but today is just a day it's our day of
you know
chilling it's our day of rest here enjoy
have a laugh
get a beer or coffee whatever you want
wait what is this coffeezilla
motivational song and performance just
do it
what and it's deep faked in everything
this is incredible coffeezilla making
fun of
fake gurus here we go
[Music]
how are these deep fakes so good that's
a deep fake
what is this
[Music]
this is so creepy dude it's amazing
though at the same time
oh my gosh i have to give this guy gold
obviously
stop it kung fu zilla all right we got
this guy
amateur hour over here right here no way
guys i'm a real i mean i learned the
death touch guys don't mess with me
i'll death touch you next meme the fake
guru figuring out how to out compete
honest experts
get rich a few people show up
quick everybody in the city
yeah um sorry that's how it works i call
this song give me platinum oh yeah
i'm coffeezilla i'm a tryhard at life
than a guru
killer oh this is sick okay hey
settle in all right i'm a daily uploader
and have dank content why are you
ignoring my argument oh what's that you
call me fake news well listen here buddy
you're
going on youtube my task is simple
it's super easy i got 10 million dollar
studio in a lamborghini
i'm gonna expose every guru in the
nation i don't like pop we're on the rap
station time to repent and admit your
sins i'm not falling for your scam or
collecting any dividends
yo kids got flow okay what do you guys
think hey dude
wait a tr way to put out your best i'm
gonna say this right now i don't think
anyone's tried this hard
uh good job let me say it's a lot better
than if i would have rapped a few times
there i will
say seem like you're fit trying to
really fit in
a word but i'm going to go ahead and
upload that i'm rooting for that song
that's a pretty good song
next meme guys here's all bribery
sipping on wee-wee again
thought i'd go for a chill laid-back
subtle vibe i hope you like it best
community on earth
well thank you let's listen in excuse me
i'm just so nervous
[Music]
here's the way it works here's me and
here's the
five company one at a time underneath
underneath underneath and here's the
five persuasive words that you can use
to
control dude you guys are so creative
it's insane
got it and here's the five bye bye bye
five
coins to five million dollars so that
it's you yes and here's the five
companies one at a time
underneath underneath underneath got it
i have important information it's not a
product that i'm selling
okay go ahead it's a straightforward
business how to discover your passion
how to get paid for it it's a
straightforward business
but you want to make maximum wages are
you ready to be
famous literally
the most valuable thing you've ever been
a part of your entire life well one of
the least valuable things you've ever
been a part of the biggest waste of your
time
the biggest waste of your time dude the
one true thing they actually said
hold on can you finish that analogy for
me so that it's you
yes me yeah and here comes the five
dragons underneath underneath got it
everybody that you bring in they're
gonna bring in so i start here
yes and then it gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
and bigger
what did i just make it's not a pyramid
large
dude this is so high quality i wasn't
gonna watch the whole thing but
literally it's so good green
came across a book he read that book
he was so inspired by the author of that
book
you have developed a very special
relationship
and it took me on as a mentee i was
broken
i didn't have a college degree i had no
opportunity
but you know what something happened
that changed my life
i bumped into a mentor and another
mentor and a few more mentors i've found
five five five mentors never
underestimate
the power of having this mentor
five mentors and they took me on as a
mentee
my mentor hold on can you okay i'm sorry
because i feel like my reaction probably
seems so like over dude i am blown away
right now i don't know how to tell you
guys that
let's uh shout out to his channel dude
this is incredible oh it's called
memezilla with one subscriber
uh i'll subscribe and i'll put the bell
on dude
let me say this guys y'all are so
talented mike my community is one of the
most talented communities y'all are
insane
okay here we go here's another song
finally uh i
made music just like you asked 48
uploads i think that's the highest so
far
my garage my garage lamborghini
lamborghini
lamborghini here but you know what i
like college money
and knowledge
subscribers
okay okay you know what i'll share with
you guys a little surprise
uh that is from our very own
ukrainian designer so i feel like i
don't know if that's
is that a conflict of interest for me a
little bit he's our he's our 10 million
studio designer also making beats pretty
good
answer policy name first brian rose for
mayor
dude is anyone voting for that man i i'm
dying to know
the results when they come in i want an
exact number of people who voted for
bride rose i want to know who they are
my challenge entry for the lazy reddit
saturday theme song
show me some love if you like it link to
the youtube video let's go
else to do today coffeezilla all the way
it's lazy ready saturday
[Music]
seafood won't you come and play show
your flock the only way
what are you talking about flock stop
stop
this is what i want to constantly avoid
okay yes
i have a subreddit okay does that make
me
an inspirational speaker no i keep
telling you guys you
you don't need a guru go read a book or
something
[Music]
we will be okay sifu's here to stay
it's lazy red it's saturday oh
crazy actually probably one of the best
ones i've heard so far
it's so good congrats man great job
that is an instant gold my friend
instant gold boom
uh great job thank you that was
wonderful this is my theme song
submission
i'm new to this so please show mercy
okay
i'll be nice to you but uh better be
good this better not be like a rick roll
or something
[Music]
i bought a course and i got scared
he was just a piece of crap
i bought of course just to try
dang it you got me to say to be nice
before i i started this video
it's like okay i hope that coffee
demi
[Music]
oh this is an incredible thing dude i
love this
you guys i love it i love the great
submissions i love
that were the ones where you just go for
it and i'm gonna upvote you sir
what i'm about to share with you guys
next is the one post that i have seen
because somebody sent it to me
coffeezilla on wall street this is
maybe the most incredible thing that
i've seen i don't know what you guys are
doing but
y'all so talented sup what do you guys
deep faked me into the wolf of wall
street my name is jordan
what is this dude alfred year i turned
26 i made 49
million dollars which really pissed me
off because it was three shy of a
million a week
how does this work i don't know how any
of this works it's like magic
[Music]
okay it kind of looks like me right
there that's like the one where most i
was like
i is this guy going to impersonate me
with something with some deep fake this
guy is
incredible what is this dude all right
guys that completes it we've covered
everything
wow i feel like i feel like uh y'all are
insanely talented some of you some of
you
are posters we already knew that and i'm
sure that's gonna continue to be the
case but don't you stop doing you in the
back
if you're if you're posted memes that's
all right that's what we like dude
let me just say the winner today is
gonna of course be
be memorable pro uh actually the
ukrainian designer i don't know if
is that insider trading like is that
fair that this guy won
um i don't know but he's gonna be our
he's gonna be our subreddit theme song
for
now guys let's listen again into it okay
this is what you guys chose yeah don't
ever tell me that
i don't listen to you guys because this
is now our theme song uh my garage
lamborghini lamborghini lamborghini
all right i can live with it it's a it's
a nice thing i hope you enjoyed this
video hey
you for this next week on subreddit
saturdays
i want to hear from you guys who've lost
money with scammers tell me your story
and of course uh i will make some
contest rules i don't want to tell you
what the rules are until we start
because i don't want to like influence
y'all's answers but just put in
your biggest scam story uh you know who
you lost money
to tell me what happened and uh yeah
i'll
decide then who gets platinum whatever
same kind of rewards as usual but if you
want to join if you want to participate
if you want to win imaginary credit join
coffeezilla underscore gg our slash
coffeezilla underscore
gg great community over there 1500
people strong already it's where the
party's
happening at and honestly some insanely
talented stuff
there's memes that i don't even get to
that you guys haven't even seen over
there you gotta go check it out go
participate go
submit some stuff don't just lurk don't
be a lurker so that's it for today hope
you enjoyed
submit to the next contest make some
memes thank you
for watching and as always i'll see you
in the next one guys
not gonna be bald today guys
in my garage or my garage lamborghini
lamborghini
lamborghini here but you know what i
like college money
damn knowledge